guess what it's mondays it's our
favorite days around here because it's a
great way to kick start the week
it's time for pop quiz
okay our vff brenda you have been
selected hi brandon
[Applause]
all right
oh fred i'm so excited that you're here
and if you
answer the three questions about today's
show
you'll win one thousand dollars
but for every question you get right
well how much do they get 100 you get a
hundred dollars
that's good all right brenda are you
ready yes
drew yes okay here we go
first leslie mann revealed she took up a
hobby during the quarantine
what was that she's
roller skating with me
all right second question beth was
sitting in front of a piece of
art during her interview what was on the
piece of art
oh it was a a a portrait of horses
yes yes yes okay and
i get so excited i can't believe it okay
finally
there was a makeup palette collab that
we talked about in the news what 90s
company is in the collab
four thousand dollars i cannot even
believe that they're doing that it's a
blockbuster eye palette
you're so cute thank you so much
oh brenda i'm so happy for you and thank
you for not only playing along but
paying such good attention thank you
and thank you to anyone else who may be
kind enough to be watching and certainly
all of our vff's our crew who is our
family
and rossi thank you thank you thank you
we hope you have a wonderful rest of
your day
[Music]